[Musique]
quand on rentre sur un plateau et louise
et je vais faire un signe des mains
c'est sympa oui mais si vous faites ça
c'est plus introduit enfin je veux dire
c'est pas c'est presque ça non alors le
coeur il est comme ça oui c'est vrai ça
si vous rentrez que ça c'est vous êtes
saisonnière dans un camping naturiste
d'accord ces luminaires aux quads sont
les meilleurs ainsi pas ma mentalité
so cool ils sont aujourd'hui déjà dans
un premier temps avec le masque de
commencer l'émission on annonce que
c'est fini le corps d'un virus s'est
terminée vous pouvez tous en 0 visage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout nu pour interpeller le gouvernement
plutôt que de bloquer les routes
voici le mode d'action choisi par les
agriculteurs bio car l'aide au maintien
dont il bénéficie devrait fortement
baisser selon des premiers arbitrages
autour de la nouvelle pac
quant à elle par bos au mieux de gens
tout nus ça vous dérange pas non du tout
d'accord on et vacanciers la bottine
ah mais ça ne l'avait pas dit assez
super elle nobel nous a dit que c'était
une ambiance sympathique naturiste
quelle est la petite bébête qui ai fait
le plus votre compagne vient d'enchaîner
sans hésiter l'asticot et puisqu'on
parle voilà quelle transition vous allez
bien vous savez quoi je vais pas faire
de transition où les français cache-t-il
leurs textes directs comme question là
où je prends le plus de joie de
jouissance et de plaisir c'est sur un
canapé dans ma baignoire ou dans mon lit
année des séquelles ça parce que les
noms de vos émissions ont plu mar 21 cm
c'est un peu l'esprit mal placé car je
trouve intéressant que vous me disiez ça
va ce tournoi 21 cm c'est la taille d'un
livre
oui évidemment vous voyez ce que vous
voulez plus marc moi je vois pas de
connotation sexuelle à plumard je vois
la plume de l'écrivain
puis je vais aussi le lit après c'est
vrai effectivement je concède que la
littérature depuis longtemps ma [ __ ]
on a demandé à plus de 2000 français aux
îles cacher leurs jouets intimes alors
la cachette la plus répandue c'est
séduit la nuit ben oui à portée de main
c'est plus pratique vient ensuite le
dresser une cachette pour certains se
trouvent dans le tiroir de la table de
nuit
ensuite il ya sous le lit et puis 1%
cache quand même leur sextoys dans la
cuisine
s'il te plaît car là faut pas que tu
lâches
envie de faire je sais mais s'il te
plaît ne lâchons rien alors on a besoin
d'être les deux s'il te plaît garni moi
tout ça c'est une bêtise vous propose le
temps d'une partie de souffler de vous
abandonner et de lâcher prise vous
verrez la vie est tellement plus belle
quand on s'emballe et kenz mais surtout
mon chiffre préféré de ce sondage
22% des français sont incapables de dire
où ils ont rangé leurs c'est qu'il est
temps de ranger la chambre et sont
bagués et j'espère franchement qu'on va
pas gagner parce qu'en mai
ils méritent pas je n'accepte pas me
renier au mérite pas
oui pal dems
arrête
tout ce que je voulais passer dans mon
assiette
il ya le carpaccio de boeuf ci est
impossible pour moi je mange en plus
qu'un joueur autour de moi j'ai pas
l'impression le carpaccio fait
l'unanimité aulas wouah ça fait des
années des années ce qu'est ce que je
suis plus jeune ça s'est très bien passé
ça s'est jamais dit à mes gars assez
jamais disent ces gens remettent les
abeilles je vous dis molière quoi
sert-il à des toiles et hop on attend
quand même c'est que tu prends
énormément la confiance on me supporter
je vais te dire non mais tu te laisser
passer ça va être aussi simple que ça tu
sais à tf1 ils ont su trouver les mots
pour se dégager toi c'est vrai à metz a
été direct c'était quoi dégage tu as
[Applaudissements]
envie de te dire bis repetita
geof semble à bout de moi-même et des
bêtises stupide dry non baptise idiotie
oui mon poto mamés cra en train de pécho
sagot il a trop le sommes
est ce que vous comprenez pas non c'est
que son pote la vie en train en train de
gérer ça go et il est vraiment au bada
attend il a géré ça goélands bat bail il
a géré ça go alors qu'il ne savait pas
gérer sagot c'est à dire là il est il
allé voir sa copine alors qu'il ne le
savait points je veux qu'on fasse la
paix non mais tu t'énerves tout sur mon
oncle est unique c'est fini
et on se tapait reese tampon est encore
ici et christian estrosi
vous le connaissez messieurs il est
maire de nice depuis 2008 et député
prochain qu'est-ce qui l'a tabassée
christian estrosi ça l'a fait wayne et
on s'attend un cv long comme le bras
pas du tout je vous la faire courte il a
pas eu le bac christian estrosi un bon
il ne l'a pas eu
voilà il a beau être député maire il a
pas eu c'est un garçon que vous avez
littéralement dépuceler avant il était
bien coiffé décoiffé pas maintenant vous
l'avez un petit peu salie et il est
parfait alors que c'était super mais je
peux vous garantir que moi il n'a jamais
su de monsieur c quelle belle émission
il est passionné de moto depuis toujours
il a arrêté ses études pour faire de la
compétition est ce que vous le
motodidacte c'est pour ça qu'elle rigole
parce que d'hôpital me dit tu me pourrit
pas tu dis pas son surnom tu fais
semblant ne pas le connaître
j'en appelle le motodidacte crayon très
concret oui il ya une digue entre robert
ménard et vous moi j'aime pas parler de
digues
parce que je ne suis pas un castor voilà
ça nous fait rire ou pas mal ans on m'a
dit à l'oreillette il ya quelques
instants
on va se suicider à la fin de notre
édition
je suis quand même allé de lançon il ya
des solutions faut y croire mais c'est
toujours boudé les rois pour tout vous
dire
souvent je me pose cette question
ad'abord et d'ici là
[Musique]